the labour party is back holding its
first annual conference in two years
but what is the point of this five-day
festival of political debates and who
turns up
strictly this is labour's top
decision-making body where party members
and trades unions vote on policies
but behind the scenes it's about far
more than that
one it's a big knees up by the seaside a
networking paradise for the politically
inclined
two it's a chance for the party to make
money by charging organizations to be
here and have an exhibition staff
[Music]
and three it's a major opportunity for
the leader whatever their party to make
a pitch to potential voters ask me my
three main priorities for government
and i tell you
education education and education
look what we've done in five months just
imagine what we can do in five years
[Applause]
a labor council hiring taxis to scuttle
around the city handing out redundancy
notices to its own workers party
conferences have also been the setting
for terrorism and tragedy in 1984 the
ira bombed the hotel where prime
minister margaret thatcher was staying
five conservatives were killed including
an mp
thirty one people were injured all
attempts to destroy democracy by
terrorism will fail
some believe this is labour leader
kiestama's last chance to break through
and even within the party there is clear
criticism
in terms of policy we haven't heard much
at all we're all really really looking
forward to this thank you so much
the big leaders speech will happen right
here on wednesday although they don't
always go to plan
we've created record numbers of jobs
[Applause]
[Music]
party conferences can make or break
political careers it's not clear yet if
this event will do either for kierstarma
is